zwischen Zeitenwende und doppelwums
bewegt sich die Kommunikation des
Kanzlers die beiden Begriffe stehen für
den Mann der an emotionalen Reden zu
seinem Volk er spart heute musste eine
Regierungserklärung her statt der
Verabschiedung des Haushaltes der seit
dem Urteil aus Karlsruhe neu gestrickt
werden muss und dafür gab es keine
Entschuldigung des ehemaligen
Finanzministers Olaf Scholz was wiederum
die Opposition in Rage bracht das
Vertrauen in den Regierungschef sinkt
Kanzler in der Krise scheitert die
Methode Scholz unser Thema
jetzt
phöniixrunde ganz klar
ist die Bürger und Bürger können darauf
vertrauen dass der Staat seine Zusagen
ihnen gegenüber
einhält wir lassen niemanden allein mit
den
Herausforderung ell so gebalt zu tun
haben
never das habe ich im vergangenen Jahr
versprochen und dabei bleibt
es was sie hier vorgetragen haben sind
doch rein technische Antworten auf eine
hochpolitische Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes sie sind ein
klemtner der macht ihnen fehlt jede
Vorstellung davon wie dieses Land sich
in den nächsten Jahren weiter entwickeln
soll sie haben keine Ahnung von dem was
da in den nächsten Jahren auf sie und
auf uns zukommt die Regierungserklärung
und die recht hitzige Debatte heute im
Bundestag herzlich willkommen aus Berlin
reden wir darüber mit diesen Gästen ich
begrüße Katja Mast von der SPD sie ist
erste parlamentarische Geschäftsführerin
der Bundestagsfraktion und schon seit
2005 im Bundestag herzlich willkommen
cararsten Linnemann Generalsekretär der
CDU Vorsitz der
grundsatzprogrammkommission und seit
2009 im Bundestag herzlich willkommen
steefan Lambi Autor und Dokumentarfilmer
er hat Olaf Scholz seit 2021 begleitet
für zwei intensive Buch und Filmprojekte
und auch viele andere Akteure der
Regierung helene brubowski ist bei uns
sie ist politikkorrespondentin der
Frankfurter allgemeinenzeitung in Berlin
Frau M das war eine Regierungserklärung
wo viele vorher gesagt haben da sind wir
mal wirklich gespannt was jetzt kommt
und viele hatten auch eine
Entschuldigung erwartet für das was da
passiert ist in diesem Urteil in
Karlsruhe hätte Olaf Scholz sich
entschuldigen müssen das hat er heute
nämlich nicht
getan ich finde nein aber das kann ja
jeder für sich betrachten ist aber nicht
die zentrale Frage die zentrale Frage
ist ja wie gehen wir mit diesem Urteil
des Bundesverfassungsgerichts um das ist
herausfordern das ist für alle die
Politik machen herausfordern zumindest
im Bund und Land weil es ist ja nicht
nur die der Bund betroffen sondern auch
die Landesparlamente und die
Landesregierungen vor allen Dingen weil
das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat uns auf
den Weg gegeben dass wir zwar äh Gelder
mobilisieren können für besondere Krisen
Situation und besondere
Herausforderungen aber dass wir das
jedes Jahr tun müssen und die auch in
dem Jahr ausgeben müssen und bisher
haben wir gesagt na so eine
Naturkatastrophe z.B artal ähm da könnt
es auch sein dass man länger Geld
braucht und das einmal beschließt für
längere Zeit das geht jetzt nicht mehr
und jetzt müssen wir damit umgehen aber
es ist eine aber gab's die Antworten
denn darauf gab's die Antworten wie es
jetzt weitergeht es gab keine
Entschuldigung es gab aber auch keine
Antworten aus meiner Sicht gab's
Antworten vor allen Dingen dazu was ist
wichtig
sowohl die Bürgerinnen und Bürger wissen
dass egal ob Kindergeld Wohngeld was
auch immer weiter bezahlt wird wir haben
ja keine Krise wie es immer suggeriert
wird dass wir ähnlich wie in USA
letztendlich davorstehen dass der Staat
gar kein Geld mehr ausgeben kann das ist
alles nicht die Situation in der wir uns
befinden sondern wir müssen für 2024 für
23 haben wir das ja jetzt auf den Weg
gebracht oder bringen es diese Woche auf
den Weg ähm die Fragen beantworten es
geht um viel Geld dass wir mobilisieren
müssen damit wir das bewegen was die
Menschen bewegt nämlich sichere
Arbeitsplätze für die Zukunft und den
Strukturwandel gestalten also keine
Kritik an der Regierungserklärung von
ihrer Seite Herr Linnemann der ehemalige
Bundesfinanzminister und Bundestags
frühere Bundestagspräsident Schuel hat
davor gewarnt dass man aus diesem Urteil
dass man dazu zu hämisch reagiert dass
man da jetzt gab es heute herftige Töne
in der Debatte der Bundeskanzler der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland wird
ausgelacht auch von ihrer Fraktion ist
das die richtige Reaktion auf eine
solche Krise nein auslachen ist nicht
die richtige Reaktion aber dass man so
ein bisschen Stimmung in der Bude ist
und dass es mal zur Sache geht im
Deutschen Bundestag finde ich nicht
schlimm es ist entscheidend dass die
Bürger sehen dass wir Opposition sind
und etwas anders sehen und deswegen bin
ich auch persönlich enttäuscht von der
Rede vom Bundeskanzler ich habe eine SMS
bekommen von einer Bürgerin von einer
Nachbarin von mir die sagte ich weiß
nach der Rede nicht mehr als ich vorher
weiß das bringt es eigentlich auf dem
Punkt ich habe noch nie eine Situation
in Deutschland erlebt wo die die
Unzufriedenheit so groß ist mit der
Regierung wo man es auch persönlich
merkt ob beim Scart spielen wenn ich
beim Fußball bin jeder spricht mich an
weil keiner weiß wo will dieses Land hin
was ist das Ziel ich meine der
Bundeskanzler muss ja keine
Vision titulieren sondern einfach mal
etwas formulieren wo wir hin wollen und
das das W wichtiger gewesen auch als die
als eine Entschuldigung für das was
dein ja Entschuldigung klar es ist sein
Fehler gewesen er hat diese Konstruktion
er hat einfach ich sag mal bildlich
gesprochen schuldensäcke in den Keller
gestellt und hat gesagt ich nehme die
nicht dieses Jahr sondern nächstes Jahr
hole ich die raus und dann widme ich
noch den Zweck um nutze sie nicht für
Corona sondern für andere Zwecke klar
aber am Ende des Tages möchte ich nicht
ich meine man kann es ja mal offen sagen
die Leute trauen uns immer mehr zu im
Moment das liegt aber auch an der
Schwäche der ampelpartei das hängt nicht
nur mit unserer Stärke zusammen und
viele Leute sagen wenn ihr es jetzt
nicht schafft dann ist niemand mehr da
der aus der demokratischen mit dieses
Landes dieses Land in die Zukunft führt
und deswegen keine Schadenfreude sondern
Verantwortung den Rucksack den wir
tragen der ist jetzt schon schwer klang
aber doch ziemlich nach Schadenfreude
heute vom Ton her Herr Lambi oder
klemner der macht also wer hat da jetzt
wer hat da den Ton heute verfehlt die
Regierung oder die Opposition also ich
war auch im Plenarsaal und ich war
gleich doppelt erschrocken ich war
erschrocken wegen der Planlosigkeit des
Bundeskanzlers in seiner Rede habe da
mehr erwartet und ich war erschrocken
wegen der Reaktion und ich habe das ganz
anders empfunden als in mann das war
jetzt nicht bisschen Stimmung in die
Bude bringen sondern der Bundeskanzler
wurde ausgelacht von der AFD und Teilen
ihrer Fraktion und ich finde diese
Situation nicht zum Lachen sondern sie
ist verdammt ernst und das war keine
Sternstunde des Parlamentarismus hier
geht es richtig um was und da geht es
nicht darum Stimmung zu machen sondern
gemeinsam
über alle Fraktionsgrenzen hinweg nach
Lösungen zu suchen so ist die Situation
und eben nicht zum Lachen jetzt sagen
die andere Seite sagt dann dass wir in
dieser Situation sind liegt nun mal an
der Ampelkoalition und an diesem
Bundeskanzler und ehemaligen
Finanzminister Frau probowski was hätten
sie sich erwartet heute von dieser
Regierungserklärung na ja wenn jemand
eine Regierungserklärung abgibt dann
erwartet man dass er was liefert ja also
und das war tatsächlich so das ist jetzt
schon gesagt worden dass ähm er einfach
nicht konkret geworden ist also klar ist
aber das war schon vor ein paar Tagen
klar dass es ein Nachtragshaushalt gibt
für 2023 dass die Schuldenbremse noch
mal ausgesetzt wird für 2023 ich wei es
ja auch anders gar keine Möglichkeit
gibt aber wie es weitergeht und zwar
weder konkret wie soll der Haushalt
jetzt eigentlich gestrickt sein wie was
ist mit 2024 und der Schuldenbremse
wieder darauf gab es eine Antwort noch
auf das generelle Problem dieser
Quadratur des Kreises die die Ampel ja
versucht hat hinzubekommen einerseits
die Schuldenbremse einzuhalten und
andererseits diese großen Investitionen
in den Klimaschutz und den die
Transformation der Wirtschaft und die
enormen Ausgaben für
für den gesamten sozialen Bereich
wie das zusammengehen soll was ja ein
logisches Problem eigentlich ist und
immer gewesen ist und ja auch nur gelöst
werden konnte indem man eine
Konstruktion gewählt hat die jetzt wie
sich erwiesen hat eben nicht
verfassungsgemäß ist und darauf hat man
sich Antworten erwartet also als ich
denke die Bürger haben es getan die die
die anderen Parteien haben es getan ich
denke auch die Koalitionspartner haben
es getan und
die SPD Fraktion sicherlich auch die hat
ja auch nicht an allen Stellen
geklatscht der Reder habe ich gesehen
z.B als es um die Gas und
strohpreisbremse ging war ja auch in
ihren reinen wahrscheinlich die
Verwunderung groß weil das ja vor zwei
Tagen noch geheißen hatte dass die
SBD ja ich okay habe ich anders
gesehen wie auch immer aber es war
insgesamt eine eine Rede die auch mich
einigermaßen ratlos zurückgelassen hat
und man fragt sich warum hat er jetzt
eigentlich diese Rede gehalten wenn
außer diesen Wort niemand schon kennt
you never walk alone wir sind für Euch
da keine Antwort kam Frau was hätten die
Bürger gebraucht ihrer Meinung nach weil
was wäre das wichtigste weil anscheinend
kommt ja die Botschaft des Kanzlers
nicht so an die Umfragen sind im Keller
es wird der Ampel nichts mehr zugetraut
und
Herr Scholz persönlich wird dafür auch
natürlich verantwortlich gemacht was
wäre richtig gewesen was wäre wichtig
gewesen den Bürgern zu sagen na ja für
mich also ich würde schon gerne noch mal
darauf eingehen weil äh die
energiepreisbremsen das ist ja der
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfond der Def
factor auch betroffen ist von dem
Bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteil also das
wo wir dafür gesorgt haben dass die
Menschen erstens im Winter nicht frieren
und zweitens dass wir auch die mit der
ukrainekrieg verbundenen
Preissteigerungen teilweise kompensieren
und Sicherheit geben und der
Bundeskanzler hat aus meiner Sicht heute
da was wichtiges gesagt und auch
bemerkenswertes und deshalb hat auch
meine Fraktion geklatscht deshalb will
ich das noch mal sagen er hat nämlich
gesagt wir setzen die zum 31.12 aus weil
die Energiepreise so nach unten gehen
dass es nicht zu erwarten ist dass wir
da quasi gegensteuern müssen und hat
gleichzeitig das Versprechen gegeben
geben dass wenn sich daran etwas ändert
dass wir in der Bundesregierung dieser
Koalition jederzeit handlungsfähig sind
und das ist ja die Sicherheit die die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger brauchen und
letztendlich ist für für mich als
Sozialdemokratin wichtig dass wir einen
Bundeskanzler haben der sagt die Zeiten
sind herausfordern wir haben jetzt viel
zu bewegen das werden wir im Dezember
tun gemeinsam aber wir tun das auch mit
einer klaren Richtschnur in dieser
Koalition in dieser Ampel wir haben den
Wert der Arbeit und den Respekt vor
Arbeit im Blick wir haben die immensen
transformationsleistungen der
Bundeskanzler war sehr konkret was Stahl
was Chips anging was Batterieproduktion
und vieles weitere anging und dann hat
er gesagt und wir müssen am sozialen
Zusammenhalt arbeiten und das ist dann
eben auch nicht so leicht jeden Tag ein
neues Detail in der öffentlichen
Diskussion zamen weil das ver uns
unsicher die Bürgerinnen und Bürger in
dieser Bundesregierung wird von allen
drei Partnern an einem Gesamtkonzept
gearbeitet und wenn das vorliegt wird es
auch präsentiert das heißt die Bürger
sollten sich da noch gedulden ist das
die richtige äh ist das die richtige
Maßnahme also die Frage stellt sich
schon und Frau bowski hat es richtig
gefragt warum diese Rede jetzt also er
hätte sie vor zwei Wochen halten können
oder hätte sie in anderthalb Monaten
halten müssen dann wenn es was zu
erzählen gibt im Moment gab es wirklich
nichts wirklich zu verkünden also die
Hauptbotschaft war er ist noch da und er
redet
ähm also so so kommt es bei der
Bevölkerung an da bin ich mir ziemlich
sicher das war jetzt ja keine Rede an
die Abgeordneten des Deutschen
Bundestages sondern hat sich an die
Bevölkerung gewandt und da muss mehr
kommen also es muss Orientierung geben
sie fragen was erwartet die Bevölkerung
und die wollen schon wissen wie ist die
Regierung in diese Lage geraten also es
ist um vom eine metaphor aus dem Verkehr
zu benutzen es ist ein Totalschaden
eines Fahrzeuges und hat so getan als
sei ein Blechschaden und man möchte
wissen wie ist die Situation warum sind
sie da falsch abgebogen wie ist es
gekommen welche Rolle hat er und wie
kann man das jetzt reparieren
und jetzt kann man über F reden und
technische Verfahrensfragen aber ich
glaube die Bevölkerung erwartet was
völlig anderes Herr lindn ist das der
Punkt das zu wenig erklärt wird ist das
ein Punkt wo sie weil es gibt ja nun
auch genug unionsgeführte
Ministerpräsidenten die ja woh ähnlichen
Problemen jetzt stehen durch diese durch
dieses Urteil in Karlsruhe die auch
natürlich überlegen müssen wie sie mit
ihrem Haushalt klar kommmen also wo wo
ist wie schafft man es den Bürgern ja
das Gefühl zu geben hier ist eine
Regierung die macht das richtige für
euch wie man einfach ehrlich ist man
muss ja jetzt Prioritäten setzen und das
macht Politik nicht gerne weil dann tut
man ja Menschen weh man verspricht ja
lieber das Blaue vom Himmel und das gilt
auch für uns als Opposition ich habe
auch intern in der Runde letztens gesagt
auch Friedrich merärz wir werden ein
Wahlkampfprogramm schreiben wo wir nicht
alles versprechen können und jetzt ist
dieser Fall eigentlich ein Segen für die
nächsten Generation dass man nicht mehr
ein Haushalt Bürgergeld muss wiederekürt
werden und Kindergrundsicherung sind das
die
richtigen wollen auch ab schaffen ja ich
habe bis heute noch nichts gehört vom
Bundeskanzler oder von dieser Koalition
was sie machen will wir gehen als
Opposition nach vorne und sagen wo wir
Sparmöglichkeiten sehen und wo wir gerne
wieder wachsen wollen und ich glaube das
ist das Problem dass ich Herr Scholz
aber auch die Parteien im Deutschen
Bundestag hinstellen sagen es gab dieses
Urteil aber nicht die Konsequenzen
daraus definieren der Bürger weiß doch
irgendwas passiert jetzt ja es ist ein
Totalschaden was passiert das Auto muss
kann wahrscheinlich nicht repariert
werden beim Schaden wir müssen jetzt
überlegen wie wir die Mobilität von
morgen organisieren die Frage ist aber
ob man den Fahrer
auswechselt ja das ist jetzt wohlfall
das muss die das muss die Koalition
wissen ob sie noch regierungsfähig ist
oder nicht sowohl Friedrich Merz als
auch Markus Söder haben schon Neuwahlen
gefordert was fordern sie denn ja ich
glaube einfach dass dieser
Bundeskanzler vielleicht wenn schönes
Wetter ist und solche Reden hält
wahrscheinlich gut ankommt aber wenn es
stürmisch ist dann brauchst du
Persönlichkeiten die Widerstände
aushalten die jetzt nicht überall
beliebt sein wollen aber dem Land
Orientierung und Führung
vorgeben niemand der immer beliebt sein
aber ich würde noch mal ganz gerne
nachhaken möchten Sie auch Neuwahlen
halten Sie es für richtig es ist ja gar
nicht so leicht Neuwahlen durchzusetzen
weil da sitzen ja Abgeordnete im
Deutschen Bundestag und die möchten ja
im Bundestag bleiben die kriegen Diäten
die planen damit die wollen sich ja
nicht selbst abschaffen das heißt es
müsste schon
viel Erklärung nee tut mir leid ich sag
einfach mal die
Wahrheit die Wahrheit ist dass das
natürlich Abgeordnete sich nicht selbst
abwählen wollen ist doch total normal
das kann man do auch mal aussprechen he
die Forderung von Friedrich m und Markus
Söder ist die ist doch die ist richtig
weil wir sage ich auch selbstkritisch
wir wurden vor zwei Jahren abgewählt
weil wir nicht mehr gut genug waren und
heute nach zwei Jahren sind wir Frau
Plettner wieder regierungsfähig das
Grundsatzprogramm ist fertig wir sind
geschlossener denn je und wir sind
regierungsfähig und heute würde ich
sagen ja wenn es zu Neuwahlen käme wären
wir bereit und würden es auch mit
[Musik]
durchziehen ja vielleicht jetzt z einen
wollte ich sagen zum Thema Neuwahlen
rechtlich gesehen ist es ja gar nicht so
einfach also ich finde das jetzt eine
ehrliche kann man sagen Erklärung die
aber natürlich auch ein bisschen traurig
ist weil das Abgeordnete im Bundestag
bleiben wollen und deswegen es keine
Neuwahlen gibt finde ich jetzt als
Bürgerin keine ausreichende Erklärung
aber in der Tat ist es ja so dass es von
der Verfassung her vorgesehen ist das im
Prinzip sich der Bundestag nicht ohne
weiteres so auflösen kann und wir haben
das in der deutschen Geschichte ich
meine zweimal erlebt und einmal stand es
auch da verfassungsrechtlich auf
wackeligen Beinen bei Schröders
Misstrauensvotum
ich glaube dass in dieser Situation in
der wir uns befinden Neuwahlen das
wirklich komplett falsche Signal sind
und zwar also ich ich denke immer so man
hat immer den Einruck ja wir haben eine
große Krise und schon vor dem Urteil
hatten alle den Einruck wir haben eine
große Krise weil diese migrations weil
das migrationsthema die Menschen
aufwühlt die Kommunen über fordert und
so weiter da war die Suche nach Lösung
da war das schon extrem schwierig und
man dachte also ich beobachte ja vor
allem die Grünen und deine Partei in
Aufruhr wegen der Migration dann kam das
Urteil also es kommt immer noch was oben
drauf und noch was oben drauf also der
der der Berg an Problem ist riesig und
in dieser Situation in einen Wahlkampf
zu gehen muss man wirklich sagen
entschuldigung da hat das Land andere
Probleme und da sollen die gewählten
Politiker in ihren jeweiligen Rollen
erstmal die Aufgaben erfüllen bevor man
sagt jetzt das ist wirklich nicht das
Thema das das Deutschland jetzt braucht
und vielleicht noch ein Wort z Union
weil wir so viel über den Kanzler
gesprochen haben und ich denke auch
zurecht kritisiert haben ist natürlich
die Union längst nicht so sortiert Herr
Linnemann wie sie das jetzt darstellen
das kann man schon an der Schuldenbremse
sehen heute hat Friedrich Merz so getan
als wä alleine der Berliner Regierende
Bürgermeister anderer Meinung in
Wahrheit ist ein Großteil der der
Ministerpräsidenten auch ein Großteil
der Wirtschaftsminister übrigens auch
der unions
äh also auch auch der Union der Meinung
an der Schuldenbremse müsste sich was
ändern in in der Partei wenn man sich
umhört gibt es viel Kritik auch an der
Art und Weise wie Friedrich Merz führt
er hat heute eine rhetorisch gute Rede
gehalten aber wo man auch sich fragen
kann was ist jetzt eigentlich die Rolle
ist das jetzt die konstruktive Rolle der
Union also über all das kann man reden
und über all das wird in ihrer Partei
gesprochen und das wissen sie auch also
sozusagen wir haben jetzt diesen einen
Mann an der Spitze der vollkommen
unumstritten ist so ist es schlicht
nicht ja das gibt's hoffentlich in der
Demokratie nie dass einer unumstritten
ist aber das es in Partei verschiedene
Meinungen gibt und ich sag mal diese
Situation Frau bowski die war doch
vorauszusehen als wir zwei 2009 die
Schuldenbremse verabschiedet haben war
doch klar irgendwann kommt der Zeitpunkt
wo die Schuldenbremse ein Sinn hat und
das ist jetzt und jetzt auf einmal sagen
alle die brauchen wir nicht mehr diese
Schuldenbremse gibt es doch für die
nächsten Generation damit wir wie jeder
Bürger auch einfach mit dem Geld was er
im Monat hat auskommt und letzter Satz
man kann man kann ja noch Schulden sogar
machen mit der Schuldenbremse dieses
Jahr über 20 Milliarden das ist wie bei
der Bank du kriegst einen Kredit aber
irgendwann ist Schluss und ich finde was
für die Bürger gilt muss auch für die
Politik wenn es so einfach wäre also ich
ich ich ärgere mich sehr über meine zwei
männlichen Mitdiskutanten die irgendwie
von Totalschaden reden Totalschaden
würde bedeuten wir haben kein Cent mehr
im Bundeshaushalt und können die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger nicht mit den
Rechten die sie haben letztendlich das
auch liefern und das da sind wir weit
von entfernt wir haben keine
amerikanischen Verhältnisse erster Punkt
zweiter Punkt diese Bundesregierung hat
zwei zwei Drittel ihrer Vorhaben
abgearbeitet sie ist viel besser als ihr
Ruf sie hat extreme Herausforderungen
ich bin seit 2005 Deutschen Bundestag
ich habe noch keine noch keine
Legislatur erlebt in der so viele Krisen
auf einmal von einer Bundesregierung
gelöst werden und wir haben einen
Bundeskanzler der jeden Tag jeden Tag
daran arbeitet Lösungen für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu bekommen für
die großen sozialen Fragen für die
ökonomischen Fragen für die ökologischen
Fragen und auch noch gemeinsam mit den
Bundesländern beim Thema Migration
gemeinsam Farbe bekennt und das nach
vorne entwickelt und in Europa zu einer
Einigung führt die es bis noch nie gab
ich finde nein ich finde dieses schlecht
reden der Bundesrepublik Deutschland und
der Arbeit die wir jeden Tag leisten das
ist unerträglich und es ist
unverantwortlich weil es verunsichert
die Menschen in diesem Land aber noch
mal kurze Nachfrage was denken sie denn
woran es liegt dass es dass der Ruf so
schlecht ist dieser Regierung weil
tatsächlich ist es so es gibt eine Menge
Gesetzesvorhaben und zu der Hälfte
dieser gesetzven hat die Union auch
zugestimmt also warum ist es warum steht
die die gerade auch die SPD da so
schlecht da also ich glaube
das Kön wir die Kommunikation des
Kanzlers ist nicht das Thema sondern wir
haben die Menschen sind verunsichert und
natürlich ist ein Krieg in der Ukraine
ähm das was die Hamas den Terror in
Israel macht jetzt auch das ich will
nicht dem dem Verfassungsgericht
irgendwie sagen das wäre nicht okay das
Urteil aber das sind ja alles Dinge die
die Menschen verunsichern bloß die
coronapandemie und wir haben an jeder
Stelle in einer anspruchsvollen
Koalition das ist es tatsächlich eine
anspruchsvolle Koalition die aber
gemeinsam nach was vorne will gemeinsam
Lösungen gefunden für die bürgerinen und
Bürger darum geht's am Ende des Tages es
geht nicht darum was ich mir den Kopf
gesetzt hat oder sonst jemand sondern
dass wir dieses Land voranbringen und
wir hatten riesen Staus was
den Ausbau erneuerbare Energien den
ganzen Energie die ganze Energiewende
angeht und wir liefern jeden Tag und ich
glaube dass ein Teil der Verunsicherung
auch mit diesen großen Krisen zu tun hat
und natürlich weil wir auch sehr viel
Reformprojekte angehen auch die
planungsbeschleunigung Z z.B die
ukrainekrise Herr ambi da wurde dem
hatte der Kanzler wogegen hieß es sehr
auf der ist besonnen er hat dafür viel
Respekt bekommen auch von der
Bevölkerung da stand er doch eigentlich
besser da als jetzt ich würde zunächst
noch mal was an ihrer zu ihrer Kritik
sagen also sie haben die Krisen korrekt
aufgezählt die Krise die wir jetzt
erleben ist allerdings eine hausgemachte
Krise das ist keine Naturkatastrophe das
ist kein Krieg sondern das ist eine
selbstgemachte und dann kann man schon
mal davon sprechen warum dieser Unfall
sich ereignet hat das hätte ich erwartet
von Bundeskanzler deshalb Totalschaden
versus Blechschaden das ist kein
Blechschaden das ist was größeres und
das kann man auch mal erklären auch der
Bevölkerung erklären so viel dazu
m Ukraine ja sie haben das richtig
beschrieben der Bundeskanzler und ich
habe ihn in der ganzen
Phase begleiten können für ein Film und
ein Buch hat aus meiner Sicht den
richtigen Ton getroffen das hatte sogar
Fredrich Merz heute in der Debatte noch
mal erklärt er hat gesagt ihre erste
Regierungserklärung am 27 Februar 2022
war angemessen und ich fand auch die
Unterstützung der Ukraine sogar das
zögerliche Verhalten das lange
nachdenken aus Sicht einiger zu lange
nachdenken welche Waffen werden
geliefert fand ich angemessen angesichts
der Bedrohung also insofern rede ich
nicht von einem Totalschaden der
Regierung sondern in dieser speziellen
Situation in dieser haushaltspolitischen
Situation das ist ein Totalschaden ich
rede nicht von von amerikanischen
Verhältnissen wie sie es mir unterstellt
haben sondern ich rede von einer ganz
konkreten von einem regierungsversagen
das muss man so benennen und der
Bundeskanzler trägt dafür die
Verantwortung nicht Werner gatzeer als
Staatssekretär des
Bundesfinanzministeriums sondern der
ehemalige Bundesfinanzminister Olaf
Scholz dazu hätte ich gerne ein Wort
gehört das kam nicht Chance
verpasst ja und also interessant ist ja
auch dass der Kanzler auch heute und das
kennen wir ja schon aus der
Vergangenheit auch wirklich so tut nicht
nur dass er nicht konkret was sagt oder
um Entschuldigung bittet sondern er tut
ja so als würde er so präsidial über
allem stehen also das das finde ich eine
ganz interessante einen ganz
interessanten kann man als Beobachterin
sagen Regierungsstil der auch ein
bisschen an die späten Jahre Angela
Merkel erinnert ja also so als als sei
das auch auch die direkte Reaktion nach
dem Urteil er gesagt hat ja wir
respektieren dieses Urteil auch wenn wir
anderer Meinung sind und T so als sei
eigentlich gar nicht großartig was was
passiert und das ist bei einer
Konstruktion die man sich Selb selber
ausgedacht hat und ich sage jetzt mal
einerseits die die Zustimmungswerte für
die Ampel aber auch insgesamt die
politische Lage in Deutschland diese
tiefe Verunsicherung die wir haben
dass man da nicht auch als als Mittel
gegen den Verdruss ja mal Verantwortung
übernimmt und nicht nur in der in der
Floskel sondern auch in Form von einer
also einer glaubhaften
Erklärung Herr Lambi hat schon gesagt
für das was passiert ist dass man selber
dafür einsteht also es ist ja das was
man im mit im im im persönlichen
miteinander erwartet dass jemand
sich bekennt zu dem was passiert ist und
und Fehler sind ja verzeilich ja wenn
man die Konsequenzen draus zieht wenn
man wenn man wenn man das das beseitigt
aber nicht wenn man so tut als sei das
irgendwie
übingekommen habe das nichts mit einem
zu tun und Herr Gatzer muss jetzt zum
Jahresende die Regierung verlassen und
ist das jetzt das Opfer und und alle
anderen machen so weiter und tun so als
sei das irgendwie jetzt ein ein ein
Missgeschick das ist das ist also man
kann das so machen ich will nur sagen
das ist keine Strategie um das Vertrauen
in Politik insgesamt und damit sind
Regierung und Opposition gemeint zu
erhöhen sondern genauosition ich würde
mal ganz gerne einmal nachhaken Herr
Lambi weil sie halt eben Scholz so lange
begleitet haben aber natürlich auch
Angela Merkel gut kennen und ist das so
ein Punkt wo sie sagen der man kann
einfach nicht anders oder der will nicht
anders der könnte ich muss im Konjunktiv
formulieren weil ich ihn sowohl vor wie
hinter der Kamera erlebt habe über einen
langen Zeitraum also im Wahlkampf und
auch jetzt als Bundeskanzler der ist
hinter der Kamera schon deutlich anders
es spricht auch Klartext er kann sehr
verletzend sein er kann auch sehr witzig
sein also all das was er vor der Kamera
und in großen Reden sich verkneift von
einen zwei Ausnahmen abgesehen ich
erinnere an die Rede in Falkensee da
hatte sich mächtig aufgeregt und ist
gerade zu aus dem Hemd gesprungen also
daran kann man ablesen der kann anders
sein aber er hat sich dafür entschieden
und ich würde seine Methode als die
Methode eines Sparkassendirektors
bezeichnen in dem Sinne ich mag zwar
langweilig sein aber ich bin seriös und
ihr könnt mir vertrauen und deshalb
berührt diese Krise gerade den Kern
seines politischen Stils also er will
und signalisiert den Bürgerin eure
Einlagen sind sicher das haben wir auch
in der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik
abgespeichert in der Finanzkrise 2009
als es losging mit der Schuldenbremse
Steinbrück Merkel und Steinbrück also
das ist der Sparkassendirektor Olaf
Scholz und wenn der jetzt
offenkundig Fehler macht in seinem
Kernbereich verunsichert das die
Bevölkerung und jetzt noch ein Satz zu
der Opposition wenn die Opposition sich
derartig erhebt über den Bundeskanzler
und ich komme an den Anfang zurück ihn
auslacht sagt ihr kann es nicht und nach
Neuwahlen ruft damit spielt man nicht
das ver sich unsichert die Bevölkerung
zusätzlichb genau eine politische
Gruppierung im Parlament die das nutzt
und das ist nicht die Union das ist die
AFD deshalb lindemmann sein sie
vorsichtig mit dem Ruf nach neuewahlen
also Friedrich Merz hat heute keine
Neuwahlen ausgerufen er hat in der Sache
geantwortet ich fand er hat keine
einzige Lösung geboten keine einzige
klar ja klar also erstmal hat für mich
eine herausragende oppositionsrede
gehalten wo er gleichzeitig gesagt hat
was wir machen würden fast 10% des
Haushaltes ist mittlerweile
Bürgergeld die Menschen in Deutschland
haben das Gefühl dass sich Arbeit nicht
mehr lohnt das ist einfach so
und es gibt einfach dieses fordern und
fördern vast was sie mal eingeführt
haben vor knapp 20 Jahren das gibt es
heute nicht mehr und ich habe mir die
Systeme angeschaut in den Niederlanden
ich hatte Schalten mit Dänemark ich war
in Japan überall dort gibt es ein System
dass wenn Menschen arbeitsfähig sind und
Sozialleistung erhalten auch arbeiten
gehen müssen so bei uns auch so nein
nichtin natürlich ist es so nein und bei
der Kindergrundsicherung ist linemann
sie haben zugestimmt diesem Gesetz in
namentlicher Abstimmung haben sie diesem
Gesetz zugestimmt und jetzt t ist so als
se der Untergang des Abendlandes nein
wir haben zugestimmt weil es die
Sanktionen gbt es ist gar nicht sch
meine das total total sachlich dieses
Bürgergeld werden wir in der Form
abschaffen wurde klar
gesagt wir wollen für Menschen da wollen
für menschenffen es soll wieder genau
abchaen
allein gib
Vereinbarung Arbeit m gerade gefragt ich
habe sie auch aushen lassen das ist gar
nicht schebbig das ist
Demokratie hab Vorschläge gemacht bei
der Kindergrundsicherung werden 5000
neue Beamten eingestellt im öffentlichen
Dienst das sagt der Städtebund der
Landkreistag das sind Experten das Geld
geht in Bürokratie und nicht in die
Kinder rein wir haben mehrere Vorschläge
gemacht und das ist
Oppositionsarbeit und ich sag
mal Lambi hat doch recht und das gebe
ich doch auch zu so richtig freuen tue
ich mich nicht warum weil zwei Drittel
Frau Plettner der Menschen der Politik
gar nicht mehr zutrauen die Probleme zu
lösen wir sind Nummer eins in einer
Umfrage mit 14% die CDU also 86% glauben
auch nicht dass die CDU die Probleme
löst die SPD bei ne und so weiter das
ist doch das kernprem in Deutland das
wäre doch dann mit dieser Analyse müsste
man doch sagen okay dann dann versuchen
wir es gemeinsam hinzukriegen der
Kanzler hatte ja auch im September
diesen deutschlandpakt Angeboten wäre
das nicht ein Punkt wo man sagt okay so
wie mit der Zeitenwende und der
Bundeswehr wir sind jetzt eine
konstruktive Opposition ja aber dann
muss doch wenigstens was kommen wo wir
daran glauben Frau blätner dass die
illegale Migration runtergeht das was da
gekommen ist sorgt dafür dass
komm dass die Kommunen mehr Geld
bekommen ja aber wir müssen doch wenn
wir den deutschlandpakt zustimmen Herr
Lambi dann müssen wir doch sicher sein
dass was bei rumkt ansonsten gehen doch
die Protestparteien und die
Proteststimmen unter die Decke wir
müssen doch bei unserer Überzeugung
bleiben verknüpfen jetzt gerade die
Haushaltskrise mit illegaler
Migration
fr PL hat mich gerade gefragt warum wir
beim deutschlandpakt nicht mitgemacht
haben dann ist meine Antwort gewesen
weil wir nicht dran geglaubt haben dass
man mit dem deutschlandpakt für
Migration die illegale Migration senkt
wir haben bewiesen wir haben bewiesen in
der ukrainekrise haben wir bewiesen dass
wir als Opposition auch mitmachen wir
folgen unseren Überzeugung und das wird
auch in Zukunft die Überzeugung sind
dann in dem Fall erstmal
sozialsicherungen abzusenken das
aber wenn sie so so ein Vorwurf der
zurecht ist einfach fellung sie haben
gesagt Bürgergeld und Grundsicherung Gen
jouralistin ist das völlig richtig dass
diese Frage kommt ich sag ihn nur dass
unser neues
bürgergeldsystem sozialer sein wird als
das jetzige weil in Deutschland muss
niemand arbeiten aber wenn jemand
Sozialleistung erhält und arbeiten kann
kann er nicht erwarten dass andere die
jeden Tag aufstehen für ihn das
finanzieren und damit wollen wir bchen
und ein faires System schaffen das ist
ja jetzt ein bisschen kesselbundes und
viele Einzel sortieren es mal ein
bisschen bleiben wir mal dabei bei der
Frage inwi weit kommen also wenn man
sagt viele Leute sind verunsichert und
sie trauen weder Opposition noch
Regierung eigentlich etwas zu also wo
gibt's eine Möglichkeit dass sie sagen
okay mit einer Partei wie der Union
damit man eben auch die AFD da kleiner
hält zu sagen wir machen konstruktive
Vorschläge also zuerstmal bin ich der
Union dankbar dass wir eine gemeinsame
Lösung bei der Ukraine mit dem
Sondervermögen übers äh über die
Grundgesetzänderung gefunden haben und
natürlich wäre theoretisch auch möglich
dass wir eine gemeinsame Lösung für die
großen ähm Strukturwandel Fragen und den
starken Industriestandort der für uns
alle wichtig ist auch für die
Handwerkerinnen und Handwerker den
Mittelstand da hängt ja ganz viel mit
hinten dran äh da gemeinsam vorgehen
aber Friedrich Merz hat es ja schon
abgelehnt die Ministerpräsidenten sind
das sehr viel geschmeidiger von der CDU
aber diese Lösung haben wir nicht aber
ich möchte schon noch mal zu punkten die
hier gerade gesagt worden sind was sagen
weil das Bürgergeld ich finde schon
bemerkensw hab das erst ja vor einem
Jahr ungefähr verabschiedet mit den
Stimmen von Friedrich Merz mit den
Stimmen von kstel LN mit den Stimmen von
Jens span und so weiter nach einem
Vermittlungsausschuss ich habe die
Verhandlungen mitgeführt auch mit der
Union und das Ergebnis ist sehr gut und
der Fokus des Bürgergeldes ist das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat uns mit auf
den Weg gegeben wir müssen ein
menschenwürdiges Existenzminimum in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland haben und das
haben wir und was wir neu geändert haben
ist dass wir die Menschen langfristig in
Jobs vermittel und nicht drehtüreffekte
immer wieder haben für dre Monate drin
dann wieder raus das ist für die
Familien schwierig für die Kinder die
dran hängen für die Betroffenen das ist
eigentlich der Fokuswechsel und das ist
wir stecken viel mehr Geld in
Qualifizierung und in Nachhaltigkeit in
in Vermittlung in Arbeit das ist mir als
Sozialdemokratin extrem wichtig weil ich
kann Ihnen sagen ich bin Tochter einer
alleinerziehende Mutter vier Kinder
halbtagsputzfrau sozialhilfevater kein
Unterhalt bezahlt das ist meine
Biografie haben den auf gescha vi nicht
habe ihn auch deshalb geschafft weil
meiner Mutter die Arbeit wichtiger war
als Geld vom Staat zu bekommen das ist
meine Lebenserfahrung und es gibt
verdammt viele Menschen in diesem Land
die wollen Arbeit auch im Bürgergeld 20%
arbeiten übrigens in stocken auf
parallel und deshalb finde ich dieses
verhetzen des Bürgergeldes schäbig und
falsch und ich kann ih an vielen anderen
Punkten auch aufmachen Friedrich Merz
fordert eine rückabwinung des Gebäude
Energiegesetzes das halte ich für
grobfahrlässig weil die wir wissen alle
die Energiepreise werden steigen wir
wegen der CO2 bepreiung und zwei extrem
das merken die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
heute nicht und er will sagen wir
unterstützen dich nicht bei einem
heizungskauf nur das hilft den Leuten
mit normalem
Einkommen Deut W frauos noch mal zu Wort
kommen lassen wir und ein bisschen auf
die Zeit achten frauos wenn Sie das
jetzt hören ist das der Punkt wo man
merkt also gerade wenn es wenn es darum
geht eben zu priorisieren wo wollen wir
den zukunftgeld für ausgehen wo man
merkt da kommen gäbe es keine große
Koalition mehr in
Zukunft ist eine andere Rollenverteilung
wer weiß wie es wäre wenn sie zusammen
regieren würden äh ich finde das im
Prinzip wichtig für den demokratischen
Diskurs dass es unterschiedliche
Auffassung gibt in der Sache ja das
finde ich erstmal ich finde nicht dass
der äh das es Anforderungsprofil an die
Union irgendwie sein sollte jetzt das
staatspolitische Verantwortung bedeutet
immer zu sagen ja ihr macht das schon
gut
das ist nicht ihre Rolle ihre Rolle ist
die kritisch drauf Z schauen und
Alternativvorschläge zu machen das war
ja übrigens auch ein Problem in der Zeit
der der großen Koalition dass man immer
so den Eindruck hatte na ja also vor
allem in der Zeit auch bevor die AFD in
Bundestag kam ja dass sich irgendwie
alle mehr oder weniger einig sind und
das ist ja auch das Erfolgsrezept der
AFD zu sagen wir sind die einzige
Alternative also es ist absolut richtig
dass die Union oder wer auch immer in
der Opposition ist in den Ländern sind
es andere Parteien zum Teil Alternativen
aufzeigt was halt wo es dann wo es dann
falsch und und und auch finde ich
gefährlich wird ist wenn es zu diesem
über
schwappenden unsachlichen sich
üereinander lustig machen wird also ich
fande Friedrich Merz hat heute eine man
würde jetzt sagen im Rhetorikseminar
würde man sagen gute Rede gehalten aber
der der Schaden der entsteht wenn ein
ein Bundeskanzler eine ganze Regierung
jedes einzelne mit Regierungsmitglied
irgendwie die kompetenzamt gesprochen
wird also Sätze wie ich kann es jetzt
nicht mehr ganz genau sagen aber so eine
unfähige Regierung hatten wir er kann es
nicht und auch die anderen Robert habck
vollkommen unfähig hat keine Ahnung von
Wirtschaft und all solche Dinge bringen
in der Sache gar nichts und zerstören
Vertrauen auf dass sie auch angewiesen
sind wenn sie eines Tages wieder
regieren also ich glaube dieser dieser
Preis ist ist zu hoch
für das was was Friedrich Merz dann im
konkreten Fall erreicht hat und
umgekehrt ist natürlich der Kanzler auch
gefangen in seiner ich sage jetzt mal
rechthaberischen Überheblichkeit
darüber haben wir schon gesprochen aber
da kommt er leider aus dieser Rolle dann
auch nicht raus immer zu suggerieren
dass er ganz genau wisse worum es geht
und dass alle anderen im Grunde genommen
ich sage jetzt mal salopvoll Idioten
sind das ist alles was was einem Diskurs
nicht gut tut sondern diese Grundthese
von man muss es für möglichhe K seine
Rede heute belegen na ja diese These
also ich ich finde sein sein ganzes
Gebaren zu sagen ich weiß wie es geht
das heute gemacht na er hat nicht einmal
gesagt
Entschuldigung entschuldigung aber
dieses dieses ich halte Kurs wir machen
eine richtige Politik für Deutschland
und und und sozusagen alles andere ist
verantwortungslos ich finde schon dass
das bei Herrn bei Olaf Scholz
grundsätzlich in seiner Art Politik zu
machen mitschwingt aber der
Bundeskanzler hat doch heute leidblanken
für die Gespräche wie wir es für 2024 im
Haushalt lösen wollen ganz klar gegeben
er hat eine sicherhe
Sicherheitsversprechen er hat ein
Sicherheitsversprechen an die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger gemacht und hat
gesagt ihr es gibt ein Gesamtpaket am
Ende des Tages und ich werde mich nicht
an heute abend Karsten Linnemann daran
beteiligen unterschiedliche Punkte wo
man sparen kann oder nicht beteiligen
weil genau das die der die falsche
Debatte zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt s wir
werden den Gesamtkonzept als Koalition
vorlegen und diese Koalition ist
handlungsfähig und wir werden das auch
hinbekommen gemeinsam aber also gar
nicht wer ich ganz Kur noch sagen da
dieses einfache versprechen wir werden
das hinbekommen ohne Wege aufzuzeigen
wie es geht ist nicht der richtige Weg
zumal ich auch finde und das ist aber
noch mal eine andere Diskussion die man
vielleicht an anderer Stelle führen
müsste fand ich eigentlich schon dass
auch übrigens zu Zeiten der großen
Koalition schon aber auch weitergeführt
von der Ampel dieses
narrativ
gepflegt wird von der Regierung dass man
sagt es gibt zwar eine riesengroße Krise
aber wir machen in Deutschland einfach
so weiter als wäre nichts gewesen also
man kann ja auch mal drüber reden was
bedeutet eigentlich eine Krise sei es
Ukraine sei es was auch immer und wie
viel Verantwortung trägt eigentlich auch
jeder einzelind also diese ganze
Geschichte von doppelwums you never walk
alone coronabonus und so weiter kann man
sich wirklich fragen dieses giekannen
Prinzip ist das eigentlich ist das
eigentlich der richtige weg oder muss
man nicht vielleicht auch ähm
gesellschaftliche gesamtanstrengung
Unternehmen und dann bräuchte man einen
Kanzler oder auch einen Vizekanzler der
mal sagt übrigens es gibt jetzt große
Kris und das bedeutet dass wir alle
bestimmte Abstriche machen müssen und
das ist das was Olf die sogenannte
blutschweiß und tränenrede die manche
erwartet hatten die war es ja jetzt einz
klarstellen ein Satz nur ich kenne schon
sehr lange ist ein Überzeugungstäter der
hat Überzeugung ich sag ihn ganz ehrlich
wenn Herr Scholz eine andere Rede
gehalten hätte wie z.B nach dem Ausbruch
des Angriffs der Russen auf die Ukraine
hätte er heute eine andere Rede gehalten
die Rede ist deshalb gekommen deshalb
gekommen weil sich ja
also ich habe dann nicht gelacht ich
weiß nur ich weiß nur ich weiß nur D ich
weiß nur dass aus der SPD auch gelacht
wurde bei bestimmten Sachen jetzt lass
uns mal die Kirche im Dorf lassen ich
will nur sagen Friedrich merärz hätte
eine andere Rede gehalten wenn heute der
Kanzler Perspektiven aufgezeigt hätte
ist som Herr Lambi warum schafft der
Kanzler das nicht wir haben schon mehr
darüber gesprochen dass er halt einfach
ja vor der Kamera da noch mal anders
agiert als im persönlichen aber ist er
kann könnte er es besser oder was was g
ist ja LS würde er sich beraten lassen
also wenn er uns jetzt so zuhört würde
er so denken ja vielleicht kann ich da
doch was anderes machen na
wird beraten er wurde beraten ich habe
ihn ja auch im Wahlkampf begleitet der
hat ja eine Erfahrung die sich ihm und
seinen Leuten tief festgesetzt hat
nämlich dass er mit dieser Art die wir
hier kritisieren die
sparkassendirektorart
sparkassendirektorart ist er
Bundeskanzler
geworden jeder Wahrscheinlichkeit im
Vergleich zu denjenigen die eher einer
Politik der flinken Zunge angehören also
wenn man sich die Geschichte der
Wahlkämpfe der letzten ich weiß nicht 15
16 Jahre anschaut also von perer
Steinbrück über Martin Schulz bis Armin
laschett dann haben die alle wurden
nicht Bundeskanzler sondern Merkel die
auch eine sparkassendirektorin war im
politischen Stil hat sich durchgesetzt
und Olaf Scholz hat sich gegen Armin
Laschet durchgesetzt also warum sollte
der Mann der das als sein Erfolgsrezept
verinnerlicht hat jetzt von dieser Art
ablassen und das ist auch ich glaube die
Hoffnung der SPD aber das könnten sie
besser sagen dass Friedrich Merz
entschuldigung das müssen sie jetzt
ertragen gegen Olaf Scholz kandidiert
weil er ist eben nicht Typ
Sparkassendirektor sondern eher der Typ
linke Zunge und in Vergleich vertrauen
die deutschen zumindest bislang das kann
Investment kann kann sich kann sich
ändern also aber eher dem dem Typ eher
langweilig seriös und das hat sich ja
auch darüber haben wir eben en in dem in
der ukraineekrise bislang bewährt die
deutschen Vertrauen jemanden wie Olaf
Scholz das muss nicht dieser Olaf Scholz
sein aber diesem Pol interessanter wenn
man ihm da vertraut warum kann er das
nicht umsetzen auf auf sein auf jetzt
das Thema allgemeine Sicherheit Haushalt
das ist doch Inter sehen wenn dann die
Lösung auf dem Tisch liegt ob die Leute
vertrauen oder nicht da kommt da aus
seiner Haut nicht raus und das werden
sie auch nicht erleben der Mann ist 65
der wird sich diesbezüglich nicht mehr
ändern vielleicht eine Vorbemerkung und
ein den ich noch schnell setzen will
einmal die Vorbemerkung her war kein
Investment mein der
Typ kein
Spark gut wen Menschen erfolgen in
diesem Lande und
mal aberweite
pun vielleicht ich glau meistens in der
Demokratie in Deutschland Regierung
abgewählt wurden ich glaube nicht D
Scholz gewählt wurde sondern ich glaube
dass wir 2021 abgewählt wurden weil wir
nicht mehr gut genug wen deshalb ist
Olaf Scholz Bundeskanzler GEW kein
wierspruch hat nicht gewonnen als
Parteivorsitz das müssen Sie nicht
gewonen als parteivorsit dafür ist er
Bundeskanzler geworden obwohl die ganze
Republik nicht daran geglaubt hat das
dar aber ich will noch mal ein anderen
Punkt machen zum regierungssel von Olaf
Scholz es ist anspruchsvoll diese drei
Parteien
zusammenzuhalten und W das nicht glaubt
da muss einfach noch mal drüber
nachdenken dass Angela Merkel eine
Koalition mit der Konstellation nicht
gelungen ist weder mit grünen noch FDP
und was wir in dieser Koalition haben
wir haben den gesellschaftlichen Diskurs
in der Koalition und bilden ihn ab und
es heißt Lösungen gemeinsam zu finden
braucht auch Räume wo wir uns
austauschen können damit wir Lösungen
finden und deshalb ist so wichtig dass
wir einen Bundeskanzler haben der nicht
nur ein Moderator der Macht oder so
irgendwas ist sondern ein Bundeskanzler
der mit einer eigenen klaren Haltung für
Arbeit und Respekt dieses Land
zusammenhält nach v genau das was so ein
bisschen was viele vermissen dass er
zwischen den streiänen FDP und grün
öfter mal ein Machtwort spricht wann
wann ein Bundeskanzler ein Machtwort
spricht muss er ja auch nicht jeden Tag
öffentlich machen mal ganz nebenbei und
am Ende des Tages geht's drum das Land
so aufzustellen dass wir die Zukunft
unserer Kinder im Blick haben und gute
Arbeitsplätze haben und genau das ist
unsere Leitschnur ich woll nur noch
ergänzend sagen von zu Lambi ich ich
glaube auch dass er sich nicht verändert
hat weil ja auch dieser dieser Umstand
dass er gegen jede Wahrscheinlichkeit
und gegen alle Umfragen Bundeskanzler
geworden ist bestärkt ihn natürlich auch
in dieser Haltung dass das alles was
jetzt passiert irgendwie gar nicht so
wichtig ist am Ende sozusagen
abgerechnet wird am Ende und man hat den
Eindruck dass also auch sollte er diese
Runde anschauen wird er sich
wahrscheinlich mit den Schultern zucken
und sag keine Zeit wahrscheinlich hat er
auch keine Zeit aber er würde
wahrscheinlich auch mit den Schultern
zucken und sagen ja die wissen das ja
auch alle nicht und wir werden schon
sehen was in zwei Jahren ist ja das wird
sich schon alles wieder finden und diese
also verschiedene Etappen in seinem
Leben also einerseits diese absolute
Mehrheit in Hamburg aber auch die
Bundeskanzlerwahl hat ihn dazu gebracht
zu sagen ich kann es einfach so und das
Interessante ist dass jedenfalls nach
was nach außen sichtbar ist nicht sehr
viel ihn in diesem Glauben erschüttert
und das wiederum erinnert ihn an die
späte Kanzlerin die auch der Meinung war
ich kann es und das ist immer nicht gut
also Kritikfähigkeit ist grundsätzlich
gut für Politiker weil es die Politik
besser macht und weil es die
Glaubwürdigkeit und das Vertrauen der
Bevölkerung erhöt und glauben Sie aber
dass die Ampel dann noch noch hält ich
würde sagen keiner in der Ampel hat
wirklich ein Interesse an neuwah
abgesehen von den verfassungsrechtlichen
Problemen die es ja auch da gibt und
ehrlich gesagt sollte glaube ich die
Opposition in dieser Situation auch
nicht zu laut darauf danach schreien
sondern ich glaube es würde dem Land gut
tun wer weiß ob nächste Woche die
nächste Krise kommt ja aber die Hoffnung
ist ja dass man jetzt erstmal diesen
Berg von Krisen in welcher Form auch
immer konsolidiert und abarbeitet und
dass die nächsten Wahlen dann kommen
wenn sie anstehen das wäre auch meine
Prognose übrigens und der Plan liegt
aber in der Schublade vor sie wären
vorbereitet wenn jetzt irgendwas da
scheitern würde ja sehr ich meine geht's
ja echt um viel es ist ja hier kein
keine Augsburger puppenspielkiste
sondern es geht ja wirklich hier um
Verantwortung und
die Ampel ist gewählt sie muss regieren
und wir sind Opposition machen das
konstruktiv aber natürlich sind wir
vorbereitet für den Fall der Fälle Herr
Lambi kommt der Fall der Fälle ähm die
innenpolitische äh Stimmung wird sich im
nächsten Jahr noch verschärfen ich
glaube das was wir im Moment erleben ist
ein Vorspiel für das was wir 224 erleben
werden liegt am politischen Kalender
drei aus deutscher Landtagswahlen die
Europawahl gemeinhin Protestwahl die
amerikanische Präsidentschaftswahl also
die Regierung startet mit sehr
ungünstigen Vorzeichen in dieses
möglicherweise schicksalhafte Jahr aber
der Druck wird so groß sein meine
Prognose und sie fragen nach
Prognosen und Frau bowski hat's richtig
gesagt die haben kein Interesse die FDP
müsste Bef ins Parlament
parlamentarische auszuschießen und warum
sollten die anderen beiden freiwillig
von der Macht lassen okay gut das
Schlusswort Herr Lambi Frau Mast Herr
linemanni vielen dank vielen dank ihnen
fürs zuschauen morgen schauen wir mal
wieder ins Ausland da gibt es ja nun
auch genügend Krisen wir fragen
Waffenruhe in N Ost was kommt danach und
jetzt phöx der Tag mit Mark Steinhäuser
bis dann
[Musik]
tschüss